Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In the series, we talk a lot about photorealistic
rendering and making sure that the appearance
of our virtual objects is simulated properly.
A lot of works on how things look.
However, in order to create a more complete
sensorial experience, we also have to simulate
how these things sound.
And today, we're going to have a look at a
really cool piece of work that simulates the
sound of virtual elastic rods made of aluminum,
steel, oak tree, and rubber.
And of course, before you ask, this also means
that there will be sound simulations of everyone's
favorite toy - the walking slinky.
As for all papers that have anything to do
with sound synthesis, I recommend using a
pair of headphones for this episode.
The sound emerging from these elastic rods
is particularly difficult to simulate because
of the fact that sound frequencies vary quite
a bit over time, and the objects themselves
are also in motion and subject to deformations
during the simulation.
And as you will see with the slinky, we potentially
have tens of thousands of contact events in
the meantime.
Let's have a look at some results!
For the Fellow Scholars who are worried about
the validity of these Star Wars sounds, I
know you're out there, make sure to watch
the video until the end.
The authors of the paper proposed a dipole
model to create these simulations.
Dipoles are typically used to approximate
electric and magnetic fields in physics, and
in this case, it is really amazing to see
an application of it for sound synthesis.
For instance, in most cases, these sound waves
are typically symmetric around 2D cross sections
of these objects, which can be described by
a dipole model quite well.
Also, it is computationally quite effective
and can eliminate these lengthy pre-computation
steps that are typically present in previous
techniques.
There are also comparisons against the state
of the art, and we can hear how much richer
the sound of this new technique is.
And as you know all too well, I love all papers
that have something to do with the real world
around us.
And the reason for this is that we can try
the very best kind of validation for these
algorithms - and this is, when we let reality
be our judge.
Some frequency plots are also available to
validate the output of the algorithm against
the real-world sound samples from the lab.
It is really amazing to see that we can use
science to breathe more life in our virtual
worlds.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!